hey guys um today in windows vista i'm
going to be showing you a lot of you if
you have windows vista you may have
wondered where did the run button go in
the start menu well first of all i have
to say that the run button is actually
the start search button as well if i was
to type ms config into the run in the
start search button and hit enter it
would pop up as if i put it in the run
dialog
but some of you guys who are still well
and true to windows xp
i still want to be able to just go start
run
and uh simply have that little run
dialog box there type it in just like
you were in windows xp so i'm going to
show you guys how to enable that
uh first of all you right click on your
taskbar not the actual start or but the
taskbar properties
then you go to the start menu tab
and in start menu i'm going to hit
customize
this will work for both the classic
start menu and the windows vista start
menu
so i'm going to scroll all the way down
about three quarters of the way down
until we see a box that says run command
all you have to do is check that box
and hit ok
hit apply
and press ok again
and that will apply
the run command box right there into
windows vista's start uh start menu and
that's just how you do it uh then when
you hit run you'll have ms config right
there
you can type in and it will work just
like if you typed it right here
so um i hope that guys helps if yeah i
hope that helps you guys if you're using
windows vista if you want to um
disable it at any time it's the exact
same steps just follow
the opposite way customize
go down
and uncheck run command
and apply it
it'll be gone you'll never have to worry
about it again so that is how to enable
and disable the run command in windows
vista
um in the windows vista start menu if
you like it and if you have any more
tutorials that tutorial ideas for me to
do just subscribe and send me a message
and i will get to it so thanks for
watching peace
now what i just showed you is just one
of the many forms of start menu and
taskbar customization in windows vista
another thing that i have done with my
start menu is i right click and go to
properties
go to start menu again and customize
again
and i set the number of recent programs
to display as eight
i think it is normally set to nine or
ten i decreased it to eight uh to
shorten the size of my start menu so
when i actually hit start it only goes
about
a little more than halfway up the screen
so i have one two three four five six
seven eight recently displayed items and
i have of course the ones i've dragged
to the top as my most used
in order to add icons to here
simply select the program so maybe i
want to add paint up here
i will just click it and drag it until
it's above that dark arrow and release
and there it is it will always be there
no matter how many other programs i open
in this bottom eight it will be up here
uh and to
open it you click it obviously
anytime you can move paint out of there
just by right clicking on it and
selecting remove from this list
and paint is gone so i've chosen
internet browser and my email client as
well as media center
printing and scanning etc the dvd suite
and my disk defragmenter to all be in
the top as well as the eight most
recently used programs in the bottom so
those are two little tricks for start
menu customization that you guys i like
so again if you enjoy these videos go
ahead and subscribe i'll get to you
peace